he has had a tremendous year  michael bryce is the bodyguard of the  year  [Laughter]  [Music]  is he a relative of yours god no darius  kincaid's a hitman wanted for like a  zillion murders around the world and how  often do you have this dream  just once well that's not tonight right  i'm thinking you need to forget  bodyguarding  i'm officially on sabbatical and to be  honest i don't know why  i didn't do this sooner  [Music]  this is the world's been waiting for me  to make this change  for the first time i'm starting to  imagine a life without bodyguarding  this really feels like a newbie  did i know you the muffin took my  husband  that means no guns no killing and no  blood  what is he doing here  are you using pepper spray i'm on  sabbatical  i would make a great mother don't you  think oh my god a child would be so  lucky to have you as its host  [Music]  you're gonna tell us everything you know  i'm not telling you  i on the other hand will tell you  everything  you